western-made battle tanks have
officially been pledged to Ukraine but
have the intense negotiations over
sending them exposed cracks in the
Western Alliance we are united here's a
look at what led to the major
announcements from Germany and the U.S
and the Diplomatic challenges that lie
ahead
in mid-January the UK became the first
Western Nation to send Ukraine main
battle tanks the Challenger 2. that
quickly ramped up pressure on Germany
which makes the leopard two hundreds of
thank you are not hundreds of Tanks
leopards or Leos are some of the most
advanced tanks in the world they run on
diesel and analysts say they're easier
to operate than some of the big U.S
tanks Leos are widely held by Germany's
allies and some of those countries
signaled they wanted to send their tanks
to Ukraine but Berlin was concerned
about drawing Russia into a broader
European conflict and it said it
wouldn't allow those countries to send
their german-made tanks to Ukraine
unless the United States agreed to send
their own main battle tanks the M1
Abrams that stance frustrated some
European allies especially those close
to the front lines
and the Pentagon which had already given
Ukraine Bradley Fighting Vehicles
initially opposed sending in the Abrams
the Abrams is a
a powerful system there's no doubt about
it it's also very expensive to operate
very expensive to fuel very expensive to
maintain and it requires a lot of
training but after days of intense
diplomacy the U.S reversed course and
agreed to send the Abrams tanks in a
package deal that helped unlock a supply
of Leos so Ukraine Got the tanks why
does all of this matter on one hand the
tanks Mark a big step up in Western Aid
and a symbolic victory for Ukraine on
the other hand you could say there were
cracks beneath the armor for days the
Diplomatic scramble threatened the unity
of the Western Alliance something my
colleague Gordon lubold has been
reporting on you were just in Germany
what were leaders saying and what are
some of the frustrations they're
expressing the U.S was saying publicly
but more so privately that you guys are
if not more so have a lot of skin in
this fight you're right there on the
border you don't have to wait for us the
whole Saga reinforced the notion that
Europe is staying in Washington's Shadow
when it comes to a war on its own
continent some allies like the UK Poland
and Estonia believe Europe can't afford
to hide behind Washington anymore but
analystcent officials say that Germany's
standoff over tanks just made Europe's
response to the war even more dependent
on the U.S almost in every case where
the Europeans have made a decision to
deploy a certain kind of Weaponry or
material it comes only after the U.S has
made a counter-countering decision so
what challenges lie ahead for the West
European leaders are under pressure to
ensure that the war doesn't spill out of
Ukraine and ultimately land on their
doorsteps but as they boost military
spending some are facing backlash at
home as they try to rein in Social
programs
and U.S politics are also a concern
divisions between the Biden
Administration and the
republican-controlled house could
jeopardize future funding currently
authorized funds expire on September
30th plus with the 2024 election around
the corner there are fears that the
political will Define fund Ukraine could
slide most advocates for supporting
Ukraine are like do as much as you can
right now do it yesterday
[Music]